so in this section as promised I'm going
to describe how you would apply Bora
wheeler transform for pattern matching
and you will see that the readability
structure will allow you to reduce the
memory require significantly let's take
an example let's look search for a na in
the vex
Panama banana and as you remember this
is a matrix where the rows are on
possible cyclic rotations of the strings
because of that on the marching will
appear in clumps like this okay but of
course we don't have enough memory to
store all of these metrics all of this
matrix so we just store the four last
column as the bead ability because the
last column is no so we can also know
the first column easily by sorting so to
look for a na we start from the last
character a and we look in the first
column we can identify along the rows
that a appears and what is the next
character and we look to the last column
and we limit ourselves to n1 n2 and n3
using the first last property we can I
don't know where and one and two and
three appears in the first column so now
we already identify two letters much
right so what is next is a we just go
back and find on a using the first last
property we can again know where the f3
f4 f5 appears in the first column and in
this case na appears three times in the